c'est ce qu'on appelle un caprice plutôt
malvenue alors que lundi dernier se
déroulait depuis le staples center à los
angeles un vibrant hommage en l'honneur
de la légende du basket kobe bryant et
de sa fille ainsi que les sept autres
personnes disparues fin janvier dans le
crash de leur hélicoptère certaines
stars présentes ont fait des leurres
c'est le cas par exemple de la super
star beyonce une artiste très proche de
la famille qui avait accepté de venir
délivrer une performance exceptionnelle
pour rendre hommage à celui qui était
son ami mais aussi un fan de son travail
selon elle
je suis là car j'aime kobe et c'était
l'une de ses chansons préférées
mais voilà malgré les circonstances très
particulières beyoncé reste queen bee la
star aurait imposé des conditions
particulières à sa présence comme le
fait de ne jamais être filmés ou
photographiés par les professionnels et
le public présent ce jour là au staples
center si on sait que bien de ses
contrôler son image dans les moindres
détails beaucoup se sont étonnés de
cette demande pour eux déplacés en ces
circonstances c'est tellement
irrespectueux envers la famille de kobe
et ses fans
beyoncé contrôle trop son image aucun
photographe n'a été autorisé à prendre
des photos d'elle à l'hommage rendu à
kobe sérieusement même la famille de
michael jackson n'a pas fait ça et ce
n'est pas tout car la star ne s'est pas
contenter d'imposer cette demande
elle s'est aussi assuré qu'elle serait
respecté un membre du staff du staple
center a été déployé pour être certain
qu'aucune caméra le capturer la scène
lorsqu'elle chantait ça n'aide pas
l'image de beyoncé du tout ça lui porte
préjudice
et il n'ya pas que sur scène que les
rumeurs autour de la diva vont bon train
si les principales stars amies de la
légende du basket étaient présentes pour
lui rendre un dernier hommage
un invité de marque manqué pourtant à
l'appel lebron james un sportif très
connu de kobe bryant
selon de nombreuses rumeurs si cette
star du basket était absente ce soir là
c'est en raison de la relation
extraconjugale qu'il aurait entretenus
avec beyoncé aurait-elle fait interdire
sa présence en tous les cas une chose
est sûre lundi soir beyoncé a prouvé que
pour elle la seule chose qui compte
c'est beyonce
c'est ouf cette histoire c'est vrai
mayombo c'est fou cette histoire ouais
c'est vraiment fou tu aimes bien beyoncé
toi moi j'aime bien bhv gabas et de la
jet féminine j'adore elle est
talentueuse
bah ouais mais là et mathieu c'est fou
comme les gens parfois sur twitter où
les journalistes aiment vraiment [ __ ]
la merde parce que par le cou à la
sûreté en direct la première chanson
préférée de kobe bryant en direct comme
ça ce n'est pas donné à tout le monde
est au contraire elle a refusé toutes
les photos et tout ça pour une seule
raison c'est que pour elle c'était pas
un événement média ou un événement de
presse travaux c'est uniquement un
hommage et les gens ont retourné ça pour
[ __ ] la merde
et dire qu'elle avait des conditions de
stage assez d'accord alors ce qu'elle a
fait des très très beau séduction dire
y'a pas de fauteuil à rien c'est
uniquement à la pourchasser d'accord
mais je suis d'accord avec mathieu la
ccc en concours où les gens qui ont
voulu [ __ ] la merde j'ai un croyant
vivent que de ça
voilà ils ne vivent que des fous c'est
incroyable ça je vous dis datant lui
coûte entre lui un supporter après les
versions l'entend jamais sûr elle
d'habitude donc là c'est sûr qu'elle l'a
fait pour les raisons que mathieu hésite
et mamie nous tu dis à des façons de
faire mais on ne connaît pas du tout sa
façon bien sûr n'était pas là bas et
kiev n'avoir rien su et mamie nova tap
que sur les américains c'est sûr que
bruxelles va pas
mais isabelle morini bosc avait chanté
en direct comme bien-être est
complètement
ils étaient ils étaient à égalité de
notoriété pour beaucoup c'est pas ça va
tellement sans dire que c'est pas la
peine d'en faire des tonnes moment je
suis pas d'accord je trouves tu as
manqué de simplicité tout ça clément non
ce qui est regrettable c'est que
finalement ne parle que de ce qui s'est
passé avec beyoncé on ne retient même
pas l'hommage qui a été fait à kobe
bryant s'est produit autour de mr de
vous dire que le sac à sapin vous va
traîner le grand moment de cette
cérémonie
c'est l extrait dont tout le monde a
parlé ces discours de sa femme la femme
de kobe bryant
vanessa qui a rendu un dernier hommage
poignant à son mari regardez
mr de basketball messieurs découvrent la
tristesse mais c'est normal c'est un
énorme moment d'émotion il faut noter
que parallèlement à ça quand même il ya
eu des plaintes qui ont été déposées
contre la compagnie d'hélicoptères
les ayants droit du pilote mais parce
qu'elle estime que l'hélicoptère
n'aurait jamais dû décoller donc elle
mène des actions judiciaires
il ya aussi l'autre moment fort de la
cérémonie sur les larmes de michael
jordan des plus grands champions de
basket de tous les tons qui a salué la
mémoire de son ami regardez nous nous
amusons un billet vert soir le monde
le mode signaux de monde wima ce week
end si american pie smida voilà donc
c'était une cérémonie incroyable voilà
et de voir michael jordan comme ça c'est
un des plus grands sportifs de tous les
temps michael jordan cité un immense
hommage à kobe bryant alors même que les
etats-unis qui a que là bas qu'on veut
faire un événement pareil comme
quelqu'un meurt ça qu'en france oui
c'était une descente a changé c'est très
beau mais c'est vrai qu'il ya que dans
ces pays là qu'ont fait les hommages
aussi magnifique c'était une des plus
grandes stars un sayan voilà un des plus
grands sportifs de tous les temps
voilà qui nous a quittés comme vous le
savez donc sa femme et enfant de la
traque est donc la compagnie
d'hélicoptères mais et les ayants droit
et du pilote voilà donc la famille du
pilote alors